[Musique]
c'est du provisoire
c'est mourir chez hendrick
[Musique]
sur les photos la maison avait l'air
moins à ce que ça
ces jours ci vous n'aurez qu'à explorer
village genre parce qu'on pourrait
explorer danse trop pourri
mon nom c'est prix driessche mais tous
les gens disent fuite ça sonne plus cool
ok pourquoi tu parles comme ça tu viens
bien d'allemagne non c'est quoi ton
problème j'ai un problème moi
[Musique]
le fantôme tu l'as déjà vu qu'elle
fantôme
nous verrons si vous arrivez à tenir
plus longtemps que les autres
drame familial a pas de big apple ça
s'est passé à 40 ans ils disent que la
meurtrière en cette maison hendrik
franchement non
[Musique]
c'est entre qui vient d'allemagne mais
surfer est possédé par le fantôme elle
est pas si terrifiante cette maison
faudrait que tu viennes venu c'est une
invitation tu vas pas me dire que tu
crois à ses systèmes chantôme tu l'as
bien je dois aussi je ne sais rien je
sais pas ce que j'ai vu à l'eau je te
rappelle que nous avons un meurtre est
aussi des bons jours en supposant qu'il
fantômes existent à mon avis a qu'un
seul moyen de s'en assurer
vernet les yeux
[Musique]
edit spi
c'est un petit village on règle nos
affaires entre eux
[Rires]
tellement
m merci
[Musique]